[Music]
thank you
Jonathan you write in this week's cover
piece for the magazine that Europe is
approaching a boiling point as gang
violence is rising up across several
countries I want to start by asking you
about the recent riots in France what's
it been like living there well in our
village it's been absolutely
unremarkable except that the
conversation in the cafe is one of
enormous
annoyance that this should be happening
yet again France is in a almost
Perpetual state of rioting and attacks
but this was unusually severe and it was
provoked by the death of the 17 year old
boy in a suburb of Paris who was shot by
the police refusing to stop for a
control and a bit like George Floyd in
America a person who did not have an
unimpeachable character now hell also
was involved with gangs he had 14
previous encounters with the police but
his killing was enough to provoke an
Insurgent really across France in these
bowlier terrible suburbs that surround
every French city and it went on for
several days hundreds of police have
been injured a number of people have
been killed the government initially
appeared paralyzed but with the uh the
police action
um it seems for the moment to have
subsided but although it's subsided the
low-level intensity of of gang violence
in France continues and the fundamental
problems are not solved no politician
seems to have a clue what to do about it
and sadly the prospect is that it could
become worse Jonathan you write in your
piece that like many riots across many
countries there will be some people who
are actively pursuing a sense of social
justice but there will be other groups
who are trying to capitalize on the
moment and cause chaos what's the
balance like at the moment in France I
would say that most of the really
violent action was committed by
opportunists and gangs uh you know
because looting sharp or burning down a
supermarket or a Renault dealer is not
really a form of protest that sort of
violent behavior is more classified as a
sort of insurrection or a criminal
opportunism there are those who've
protested the situation but even there
there's some some questions just exactly
what the circumstances were and it will
remain for the criminal justice system
to determine exactly what happened
Andrew what do you make of macron's
response to these riots well he survived
them he survived
which were much more extensive
demonstrations and pretty violent in
Paris and other big cities for a while
he survived the anti-pension reform
demonstrations as well he saw them often
he's seen this off it's all beginning to
Peter out there was a lot of um
sort of excited coverage particularly in
the Anglo-Saxon media including may I
say The Spectator online that France was
on the brink of Civil War and riots that
would bring down the government and the
Army would have to be deployed it was
all stuff and nonsense and these things
happen there isn't a country in Europe
that isn't a one police shooting away
from serious rights I mean this could
happen in every major city in Europe
even this country where our race
relations are pretty much better than
anywhere else it could even happen in a
place like Malmo and Sweden could happen
in Germany it happened in Belgium it's
built it's built over could certainly
happen in Italy it was never going to be
a threat to the government itself the
the riots were serious there were a lot
of violence there's a an underclasses
being created many of us saw it coming
years and years ago but nothing was done
about it and this underclass in the
bonjour in the ghettos in the Curry
suburb exists in a mixture of welfare
dependency and quite violent criminality
and how you deal with that because we've
dealt with it basically by just shutting
it off
there but although it's these serious
social problem it is not a threat to the
state it's an embarrassment to the state
it's an expensive danger to the state
because all these businesses have to be
rebuilt but when revolutions are not
built on rise in which the average age
of the people arrested is 17. the reason
why Lee is available in 1968 were far
more significant was it wasn't just the
students who were writing in major
cities and and going for a revolution
the unions joined in the working class
joined in as well that was a threat to
the state now the goal saw it off in the
end this was not a threat to the state
it was a symptom
an Insurgency of a deep-rooted social
problem that has taken place that has
allowed an underclass to take roots of a
particular ethnic and migrant background
in the most generous welfare state in
the world
so if it can happen in France it can
happen anywhere but I am ADD I agree
with you that it's not a threat to the
state itself but it is left Emmanuel
macron seriously diminished uh we recall
that when macron was first elected he
was on the cover of The Economist
magazine walking on water and after the
passage of Merkel uh his ambition was to
become the leader of Europe that can I
just around you that's also the magazine
that had Angela Merkel as the leader of
the World perhaps not a magazine we
should take too much notice of Perhaps
Perhaps what's it called again I I
forget but the economist I think we both
used to work there actually we did that
wasn't a lot when dinosaurs walked the
earth I mean France obviously since 1789
has had this revolutionary tradition and
this these latest events were not the
most violent there is an interesting
parallel that apparently during these
recent rights animals were freed from
the zoo which also happened in 17 89 the
difference was that in 1789 they ate the
animals so but nevertheless macron
couldn't go to the European summertime
migration and now the political Center
in France is menaced by the rise of
Marine Le Pen who is looks like the
favorite to win the next election but I
have to fear that you will only make
matters worse because she has no real
ideas for how to deal with this and in
fact across Europe nobody seems to have
a particularly good idea of how to
definitively resolve this problem of
these areas infested with gangs infested
with crime with young people completely
disconnected from education and
opportunity unemployable except perhaps
in criminality well let's Branch out
from France Jonathan because in your
cover piece you look at disruptions
happening in other countries like
Germany and Sweden well particularly
Sweden which is you know now the country
in Europe with the highest proportion of
migrants in Europe 25 percent
quintessential example of a liberally
minded social democracy and which opened
its arms to receive these people and is
now uh the police are in Sweden I think
believe there are 38 000 gangsters
they're mostly young they're incredibly
violent uh the Swedish criminal justice
system is really quite incapable of
dealing with them I took my piece about
a Hitman who killed the wrong person was
sentenced to four years in prison as
promptly escaped but was granted Swedish
citizenship simultaneously and now in
teachers teachers in Sweden are being
told by their students it's you're worth
four years I can do I can kill you and
I'll only get four years for it so that
shows the the degeneration of Swedish
Society into something that is really
threatening to its reputation Andrew
Jonathan's piece he also talks about
migration and the potential connection
between what's been happening there and
the riots I wonder sometimes especially
when we're looking at Asylum Seekers and
how they're coming into the country is
the issue the systems themselves or a
lack of a system in the UK for example
there basically is no functioning Asylum
system there are very few legal Pathways
for Asylum Seekers to come here only
from a few select countries and you end
up in a position where you don't know
who a lot of the people coming into the
country are is the issue of failure of a
system or just a complete lack of a
system in place well I don't think it's
Asylum Seekers that are writing it's
economic it's migrants or actually in
the case of Francis people who were kids
who were born in France you know they're
French but they don't feel part of
French society and it's quite hard to
know exactly what could be done about
this after all one of the features I
mean the ghetto is an American
expression and one of the features of
the ghetto historically is in the 60s or
70s was mass unemployment well actually
there's a huge labor shortage in in
France at the moment people are crying
out for labor that's true in Britain
it's true in Germany as well it's even
becoming true in in Italy it's certainly
true in Sweden who've been talking about
so it can't be that you have a a kind of
unemployed youth there I think a lot of
these youngsters have found it
culturally more attractive to be
involved in low-level crime uh than to
have a proper job much to the despair of
their parents who are first generation
migrants and wanted to make it in France
or in the countries that they've gone to
so I don't think it's the Asylum system
I think it it is a problem of
assimilating migrants it's turned out
now the Europeans were always terribly
Superior when they looked at the United
States and America's race problems and
all the discrimination and the
difficulties and and so on and the riots
that they had in the 60s and why
thoughts and Harlem and so on well they
don't look so Superior now because
actually Europe excluding Britain Europe
has proved to be much less capable of
assimilating and absorbing large numbers
of migrants than America which is built
in migration or even Britain and one of
the problems that France faces Germany
has it to some extent too is that the
migrant population there first second
third generation particularly in France
are all almost one of a kind they are
nearly all of North African extraction
or origin or culture and they're nearly
all Muslim whereas if you look at the
British migration picture it's
incredibly varied you know Christians
from uh Africa Hindus from India
including our own dear prime minister uh
is is from from their Muslims yes as as
well uh West Indians Africans
sub-Saharan North African
subcontinent Middle East Afghanistan now
Ukraine much more varied which therefore
means within Britain you get
differential performance among migrant
group so Chinese migrants perform better
than anybody way better than the
indigenous white population those of
Indian extraction perform really well
too those of Pakistani extraction less
well but you don't get a kind of uniform
picture whereas in France and to some
extent in Germany too because all the
migrants are roughly the same background
not all of them but a lot of them you
get the same problem repeated again and
again whereas you go to Leicester in
Britain you'll see a thriving migrant
City
go to Rochdale
you see a not so thriving migrant City
I'd have to say coming back to England
for one of my brief visits I want to
slightly encouraged by the different uh
situation in Britain compared to France
I think in France there is really a an
almost institutional racism these kids
have very little access to higher
education the women are invisible
whereas I come to London and I see The
Splendid example of how people can rub
against each other and live happily
which is not say that Britain is
necessarily it may just take one place
you know the rights in Britain too we've
had you know there are local
difficulties
um the idea of an of a national eruption
is somewhat improbable yes in in Britain
compared to France well that's the last
question I want to put to you Andrew you
mentioned this at the start of our
conversation that you think that these
kinds of disruptions these kinds of
riots could be set off in other
countries do you think other European
leaders are looking at the situation in
France and to some extent Sweden and
Germany and thinking we could be next oh
I think there's no question about that I
think every leader in Europe including I
I would suggest our own dear prime
minister should be thinking this too
that we're all only one police bullet
away from a riot uh particularly if that
police bullet is fired in suspicious
circumstances
circumstances that become hard to defend
whatever we'll find out in the end more
visible on social media yes and social
media has made it much worse certainly
has made it much worse and this was
demonstrated with George Floyd in
America with these things were
propagated and of course one of the
things that macron has done is imposed
really quite quite tough censorship on
social media for the diffusion of these
videos which can certainly backfire if
people think well you'd think this was
the action of a totalitarian state and
I'm no fan of macron but he has a point
that that Twitter and Instagram create a
kind of mass a mass sort of psychosis in
which people see people doing terrible
things and imitate it
the final point though that I'd like to
throw into this is just as in France
we're seeing the rise and Rise of Marina
Le Pen and her her renamed National
front the Russian national there is I
think this is going to track Europe more
broadly to the right and we're seeing in
Spain as a general election coming
coming up in which the traditional
socialists are being outpaced by a
right-wing party and we see this uh we
see this in Italy where Maloney as prime
minister she's often described as
extreme right she's not extrema but they
are right the problem is that in common
with all these right-wing politicians is
none of them really have a clue a lot to
do and they like all politicians they
think that saying something is the
equivalent of doing something so you're
hearing a lot of words we have to cure
this problem we have to address the
issues but what exactly are the policies
I mean the Europe has had a lost decade
yeah
you know after the Euro crisis of
unemployment rates were you know scary
among youngsters I mean the unemployment
rate in Italy among young teenagers
reached 40 percent at one stage it was a
disaster and I think there's a danger is
that Europe now faces a second lost
decade too particularly if the ECB keeps
on raising interest rates and tackling
money there'll be another decade of no
growth that makes it very hard to solve
problems I don't say growth growth on
its own solves the problems but it does
make it easier to deal with the problems
there's more money in the treasury to
deal with them that does help I think
the other thing related to France that I
find most scary is that these these
riots as they have in America and the
the cultural significance of America is
unbelievable I don't believe this would
be happening in France over the past
weekend if it hadn't been for George
Floyd in the first place that set the
example of what you do when when people
in the poorest part see what they think
irrational Injustice on the part of the
police you Riot you set fire and you did
this time unlike 2005 in France they
went into the city centers in 2005 they
largely stayed rather stupidly burning
their own regions their own areas this
time they were at the expensive ones and
I think the danger
as this encourages extremes so
melanchong on the left has been in there
stirring things up he's a kind of
pujitis populist of the left and of
course as Jonathan says Madame Le Pen
has had a new lease of Life the real
danger in France is that the mainstream
right and the mainstream left are dead
in the water macrame killed them they
barely exist but macron can't run again
as president and I suspect his party
falls apart when he goes that it has no
future Beyond macro so what's the
political response the center cannot
hold to quote an Irish poet and the
extremes are rampant
and the riots make that worse I think
that's the political danger of what
happened in France over the past week
Andrew and Jonathan thanks for joining
me
[Music]